mucho antes de que supiéramos que era la
de ellen y antes de que supiéramos cómo
era su estructura y cómo se replicaban
incluso antes de que pudiéramos verlo y
ver cómo sucedía la meiosis en las
células teníamos la idea general de que
la descendencia era el producto de
algunos rasgos que tenían los padres por
ejemplo digamos que hay un chico con
ojos azules lo voy a poner aquí estos
son sus ojos azules aquí tengo su nariz
su boca y aquí tengo a este chico y se
va a casar con una mujer que tiene los
ojos cafés así que déjenme ponerla aquí
tienen los ojos cafés estos son sus ojos
ok voy a dibujar su nariz y bueno su
boca una pequeña boca de mujer algo así
voy a dibujar su cara y bueno un poco de
pelo para ella así que voy a suponer que
ella es nuestra protagonista ella tiene
ojos cafés él tiene ojos azules y bueno
qué va a pasar después de que se casen y
tengan un hijo bueno pues en la mayoría
de los casos o en todos los casos sus
hijos
van a ser de ojos cafés así que déjame
poner aquí a un pequeño bebé con ojos
cafés sus ojitos su nariz su boquita y
aquí tenemos a un pequeño niño con los
ojos cafés y bueno este es sólo un
ejemplo obviamente durante las miles de
generaciones de seres humanos hemos
visto que los hijos se parecen a sus
padres y además que heredan algunas de
sus características y que algunas
características parecen dominar sobre
otras un ejemplo de esta tendencia es la
pigmentación obscura en el cabello o en
los ojos esto aunque el otro padre tenga
una pigmentación clara la oscura es
dominante a veces resulta ser una mezcla
y de hecho hemos visto bastante estos
ejemplos en nuestra vida diaria ahora
este estudio de que se transmiten y cómo
se pasan las características es mucho
más viejo que el estudio del adn el cual
se volvió algo muy importante a mitad
del siglo 20 pero esto se estudiaba
desde antes se consideran a gregorio
méndez
madre de la genética clásica y es más
déjame escribir el nombre porque es un
personaje importantísimo gregorio mendel
gregorio mendel es el padre de la
genética clásica quien de hecho era un
monje y trabajó con plantas y su cruzas
con ellas y vio qué características se
pasaban y cuáles no él intentó entender
cómo se pasan las características de
generación en generación y esto es justo
lo que vamos a ver en el estudio de la
genética clásica y por eso dejan de
escribirlo aquí vamos a hablar de la
genética clásica y bueno aquí voy a
hacer varios supuestos simplificados ya
que sabemos que varias reglas no son
válidas para muchos genes pero aquí voy
a tomar la versión simplificada de la
genética clásica esto nos va a dar una
idea para predecir qué puede suceder en
futuras generaciones así que la primera
suposición que haré es que algunas
características tienen la propiedad del
todo o nada aunque sabemos que muchas no
la tienen pero digamos que esto sucede
esto es una sobre simplificación así que
hablemos del color de ojos
imagínate que hablo del color de ojos
del color de ojos y voy a decir que para
el color de ojos van a existir solamente
dos alelos recuerda un alelo es una
versión específica de un gen entonces
como en este ejemplo vamos a decir que
tenemos solamente dos opciones o tener
ojos azules a su less o tener ojos cafés
es decir vamos a pensar que vivimos en
un universo en donde alguien sólo puede
tener una de estas dos versiones del gen
de color de ojos o tenemos personas con
ojos azules o tenemos personas con ojos
cafés y bueno sabemos que lo que
determina el color de ojos es más
complejo que esto esto sólo es una
simplificación pero imagínate que vamos
a hablar también de otra característica
pensemos también en el tamaño de los
dientes lo voy a poner aquí la mayor de
los dientes
y bueno quiero hablar de otra
característica que por cierto está casi
nunca está en los libros de texto al
menos en los libros de textos
tradicionales y bueno quería tomarme
este ejemplo porque puedo decir que
también existe un alelo para los dientes
grandes déjame primero sin grandes y
para los dientes no sean pequeños así
que por aquí voy a poner a los pequeños
pequeños y quiero dejar muy clara la
diferencia entre lo que es un cliente y
lo que es un alelo como ya mencioné
antes gregorio mendel estuvo trabajando
con esto por el año de 1850 hasta que
supiéramos que era el adn o que eran los
cromosomas etcétera pero vayamos al
mundo de la biología molecular para
entender la diferencia entonces pensemos
que tengo un cromosoma y para eso déjame
dibujarlo por aquí así que bajemos la
pantalla para que pueda dibujar algunos
cromosomas así que imagínate que aquí me
tomo a un cromosoma que va a ser un
cromosoma que obtuve del papa en este
cromosoma va a existir un lugar al que
podemos también llamar locus donde
el gen de color de ojos así que
imagínate que está justo por aquí aquí
está el gen de color de ojos déjame
ponerlo por aquí pero bueno también
tengo otro gen que va a ser el gen que
heredé de mi mamá recuerda tenemos dos
cromosomas uno en el padre y otro de mi
madre así que lo voy a dibujar por aquí
por aquí tengo el de una mamá obvio
cuando están en la célula están bien y
cuidadosamente organizados pero bueno
estos dibujos son sólo para ejemplificar
un poco lo que te estoy diciendo lo que
quiero que pienses es que estos son
cromosomas homólogos entonces codifican
para los mismos genes lo que quiere
decir que por aquí en el gen de mi madre
en el mismo lugar o locus tengo también
el mismo gen de color de ojos y que lo
voy a poner así aquí también está el gen
de color de ojos ahora puede que tenga
la misma versión del gen y suponiendo
que sólo hay dos versiones de este gen
en el mundo mejor déjeme poner de una
vez abreviaciones voy a escribir una vez
minúscula para simbolizar a los ojos
azules
d minúscula para simbolizar los ojos
azules y una p mayúscula para simbolizar
a los ojos cafés y ahora una posibilidad
es que este gen tenga un ave minúscula
es decir que mi padre me haya heredado
el gen de color de ojos azules mientras
que mi madre me haya heredado el gen de
ojos de color cafés con esto puedo
escribir ya mi genotipo tengo un ave
mayúscula de mi madre y tengo un ave
minúscula de mi padre estás de acuerdo y
en este caso observa que tengo dos
alelos distintos cada una de estas
opciones es como se expresa un gen es un
alelo y entonces tengo dos aleros
distintos y dejamos que el bien eso es
importante aquí tengo dos ale dos
distintos dos
halle los distintos distintos en este
caso que tengo dos al de los distintos
voy a decir que mi genotipo es
heterocigotos déjame ponerlo aquí en
este caso estoy hablando de ser
heterocigotos pero si voto
también se dice que tengo un genotipo
heterocigotos y el genotipo no es más
que la versión exacta de los alelos que
tengo veamos otro ejemplo imagínate que
tengo una minúscula de ambos padres
tengo b minúscula b minúscula en este
caso tengo dos alelos idénticos y cuando
tengo dos aleros idénticos es decir
ambos padres me dirán la misma versión
del gen en este caso se dice que tengo
un genotipo homocigotos o
si voto dicho de otra manera
soy un monigote para esta característica
y puede que ahorita estas diciendo hey
eso está muy bien pero estas
características que tienes es decir
tienes un alelo para juzgarte es de tu
mama otro de ojos azules para tu papá
cómo puedo saber si mis ojos van a ser
azules o cafés y en realidad esto es muy
complejo porque es la combinación de
varias cosas pero recuerda que estamos
haciendo una simplificación así que
ahora vamos a introducir el concepto de
dominancia y de hecho fue justo méndez
quien la introdujo le llamamos
dominancia déjame ponerlo aquí
lancia a la idea que nos indica que una
de las características domina sobre la
otra
originalmente muchas personas pensaban
que el color de ojos especialmente el
color de ojos azul siempre era dominado
por la otra característica y para este
ejemplo nosotros vamos a suponer lo
mismo recuerda estamos haciendo una
simplificación así que en este caso voy
a decir que el color de ojos que hace el
color de ojos que hace va a ser
dominante
mientras que el color de ojos azul el
color de ojos azul va a ser recesivo de
ser vivo entonces si este fue el caso y
regresamos a este caso que tengo aquí si
yo fue a heredar este genotipo b
mayúscula o minúscula tendría los ojos
cafés porque recuerda que mencioné que
la b mayúscula representaba a los ojos
color café está justo aquí y es una
característica dominante mientras que la
vez minúscula es una característica
recesiva por lo tanto vas a tener de
genotipo los ojos color café así que
para eso voy a bajar un poco la pantalla
para que sigamos trabajando en ello
justo aquí voy a hablar del genotipo y
el fenotipo déjame ponerlos con este
color aquí voy a hablar del genotipo no
tipo y por acá voy a hablar del fenotipo
de
el genotipo son las versiones que tienes
de un gen específico mientras que el
fenotipo es lo que expresas o lo que se
ve el fenotipo entonces si obtengo de mi
papá el alelo que codifica para los ojos
color café y por parte de mamá el alelo
que codifica para los ojos azules
entonces debido a que tengo el alelo
para los tubos cafés y sabemos que es
dominante y también sabemos que la
versión de los ojos azules es recesiva
lo que se va a expresar son ojos cafés
así que en este caso voy a tener ojos
ojos color café
ahora pienso en lo siguiente imagínate
que tu mamá va a ser la que te dé el
alelo de los ojos cafés mientras que tu
papá te va a heredar el alelo de los
ojos azules que se va a expresar de esto
bueno pues estoy seguro que vas a ver lo
mismo vas a tener que el café es
dominante el azul es recesivo y por lo
tanto el fenotipo también va a ser ojos
color café ojos cafés
y ahora imagínate el siguiente caso
imagínate en el caso en que tu papá te
va a dar el alelo de los ojos cafés y tu
mamá también te da el alelo de los ojos
cafés entonces en este caso tus dos
padres te están dando el alelo de los
ojos cafés si tengo dos alelos
dominantes a estoy seguro que vas a
eliminar como se van a ver tus ojos tus
ojos se van a ver de color café también
estás de acuerdo
y sólo queda una última combinación
debido a que solo tenemos dos tipos de
alelos en nuestra población imaginaria
porque de hecho para la mayoría de los
genes hay más de dos tipos por ejemplo
para el tipo de sangre de cuatro alelos
nuestra última combinación sería tener
dos alelos de ojos azules estás de
acuerdo un alelo de ojos azules de mama
un alelo de ojos azules de un papá y en
este caso como sabemos que es una
característica recesiva pero no hay
nadie que la dominen entonces en este
caso el fenotipo van a ser ojos ojos
azules azules de nuevo quiero repetir te
que esto no es necesariamente el modo de
actuar de los alelos para el color de
los ojos pero es un buen ejemplo para
explicar cómo funciona la herencia pero
bueno existen otras características que
sí pueden estudiarse a partir de esta
misma forma sencilla lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es mostrarte que hay
distintos genotipos en todos estos son
distintos genotipos pero ahora date
cuenta que hay distintos ken o tipos que
codifican para el mismo fenotipo estos
tres codificaron para el mismo fenotipo
de ojos cafés por lo tanto sólo puede
mirar el color de ojos de alguien no
puedes saber si son como si otros
dominantes como en este caso de aquí en
este caso de aquí tenemos un homo cigoto
como si cotto dominante estás de acuerdo
ante o si son heterocigotos como en este
caso en este caso estos dos son
heterocigotos déjame ponerlo así
sin votos que también se les conoce con
el nombre de híbridos pero la palabra
híbrida o ese término es un poco
sobrecargado se usa para varias cosas
así que prefiero llamarlos es de los
cigotos pero el contexto significa que
tienen distintos alelos de un gen así
que pensemos qué es lo que va a pasar en
el siguiente escenario
imagínate que ahora tenemos dos padres
que son heterocigotos déjame bajarle un
poco para camps y esos padres se van a
reproducir así que van a existir
distintos escenarios como solteros y
godos voy a decir que empapa déjame
ponerlo por aquí el papá va a tener un
alelo de mayúscula y también va a tener
un alelo de minúscula mientras que mi
mamá va a tener un alelo de mayúscula y
un alelo de minúscula porque ambos son
heterocigotos estás de acuerdo
mi papá va a tener el alelo dominante de
ojos cafés y el alelo recesivo de ojos
azules y mi madre también déjame ponerlo
y subrayar lo justo como lo ponen en los
libros por convención siempre acá arriba
estamos
hablando del padre del padre y acá abajo
estamos hablando de la madre
madre ahora imagínate que tú no sabes el
color de mis ojos y que alguien te dice
este es el genotipo de los padres y
después te pregunta cuáles son los
genotipos que pueden tener sus hijos y
para eso voy a dibujar una cuadrícula
déjame dibujar esto en cuadrícula para
ver todas las posibles combinaciones que
puedan tener justo los hijos de dos
padres que son heterocigotos si quieres
dejarme quitará un poco esto de aquí
esto de aquí y bueno vamos a pensar en
qué es lo que va a suceder y bueno como
sabemos mi padre tiene un par de
cromosomas homólogos déjame podemos aquí
tengo 12 cromosomas justo aquí y otros
dos cromosomas justo aquí y bueno uno de
esos cromosomas del par tendrán en el
locus de color de ojos el alelo color
que hace lo voy a poner justo por aquí
mientras que el otro alelo va a tener en
el locus de ojos
al elo de color azul y sucede lo mismo
con mi mamá
imagínate que aquí tengo sus dos genes
por aquí voy a poner a uno y por aquí
voy a poner al otro y de igual manera en
el locus o en el lugar de color de ojos
aquí este gen va a tener el alelo de
color café mientras que este otro va a
tener el alelo de color azul estás de
acuerdo y como vimos en la meiosis los
cromosomas primero se replican y
entonces tienes dos cromáticas en un
sordo cromosoma y esos cromosomas se
alinean durante la meta fase de la
meiosis 1 pero como no sabemos cómo se
alinean mi mamá me puede dar este
cromosoma o este cromosoma y mi padre me
puede dar este cromosoma o este
cromosoma entonces puedo tener
cualquiera de estas combinaciones por
ejemplo si obtengo en mi padre el
cromosoma b en mayúscula es decir el
cromosoma de los ojos color café y de mi
madre el cromosoma de los ojos color
café también llegaría a esta posibilidad
mi genotipo para el color de ojos será
mayúscula
ahora también puede ser este caso de
aquí si obtengo del cromosoma de
mayúscula de mi madre déjame ponerlo así
es decir el cromosoma de color de ojos
con el alelo café y que mi padre me dé
este de aquí es decir el cromosoma de
color de ojos pero de color azul va a
pasar lo mismo justo aquí voy a obtener
a esta de mayúscula de mi padre y está
en minúsculas de mi madre déjame poder
decir esta vez minúscula de mi madre por
lo tanto mi genotipo va a ser de
mayúsculas de minúsculas y bueno falta
este caso de aquí en el cual mi madre me
va a dar este cromosoma que tengo aquí
ve en minúscula y mi padre me va a dar
este cromosoma que tengo aquí en
minúscula y en este caso tengo el
genotipo de minúsculas de minúsculas muy
bien ahora vamos a preguntarnos cuáles
son los fenotipos posibles y como ya
vimos está el fenotipo que tenemos aquí
en este tecno tipo que tenemos aquí y
este tipo que tenemos aquí como ya vimos
acá arriba nos van a dar un hijo con
ojos cafés pero este de aquí nos va a
dar
un hijo con ojos azules estás de acuerdo
ahora imagínate que te dijera tengo dos
personas que son híbridas o que ambas
son de los sigo estás para el color de
ojos por lo tanto cada una tendrá un
alelo para el color café y un alelo para
el color azul justo como estamos viendo
y que el color de ojos depende de las
reglas de dominancia y receptividad que
acabamos de ver si estas dos personas
tuvieran un hijo cuál es la probabilidad
de que el hijo tenga ojos color café
déjame ponerlo aquí ojos color café ojos
color café bueno pues fíjate en estos
cuatro escenarios cada uno de estos
cuatro escenarios son igualmente
probables y bueno si existen cuatro
escenarios entonces ese va a ser mi
denominador ese va a ser mi denominador
y cuántos de esos escenarios dan como
resultados ojos de color café
bueno pues 12
por lo tanto aquí voy a poner tres y va
a ser de tres cuartos esta probabilidad
es de tres cuartos o podemos decir que
existe una probabilidad del 75% y
siguiendo la misma lógica si te pregunto
cuál es la probabilidad de tener un hijo
con ojos color azul ojos color azul
bueno pues va a ser un escenario de
cuatro posibles por lo tanto va a ser un
25% ahora imagínate que te pregunto cuál
es la probabilidad de que tengan un hijo
heterocigotos déjame ponerlo aquí cuál
si un voto bueno en este caso no
estaremos preguntando por el fenotipo
sino por el genotipo entonces de estas
combinaciones cuales son heterocigotos
recuerda que son heterocigotos cuando
tenemos una mezcla de los dos alelos
como en este caso y como en este caso
así que cuál es la probabilidad bueno
hay cuatro diferentes escenarios y de
estos dos son los que me dan
heterocigotos entonces tengo dos cuartos
o un medio o podríamos decir que un 50%
está de acuerdo
usando este cuadro de pu net y claro
haciendo varios supuestos acerca de los
genes y suponiendo que los alelos son
dominantes y recesivos podemos hacer
predicciones acerca de los diferentes
resultados y sus probabilidades como
veremos en futuros vídeos también
podemos hacer el proceso a la inversa
podemos decir dado que esta familia
tiene cinco hijos con ojos cafés cuál es
la probabilidad de que ambos padres sean
heterocigotos y va a ser bastante
divertido esta es un área muy
interesante aunque a veces se sobre
simplifiquen las cosas sin embargo
características especialmente algunas
que estudio mendel se pueden estudiar de
esta manera